- On this episode, I talk
about being an actor,
being a mom, and being a recent graduate.
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hello everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 70
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Lovely Monday morning,
goddamn icy, rain, snow mix
in New York has completely
flipped my entire schedule.
It's insane, the lack of
grit in New York City area
right now is pissing me off.
The fact that I've had
seven different meetings
cancelled today, is disturbing at best.
If you're watching this show
and you cancelled on me,
yes, I'm calling you out. You're soft.
Alright, excited about the show,
the last episode was super great,
tried to get one in on Friday,
but then we got crunched
at the last second.
Almost got a fiver in last week,
which would've been insane.
Wanna thank all the VaynerNation
listening to the podcast
and watching the show, enjoying
it, we've hit a milestone,
episode 70, little fun fact,
I don't know if you know this.
But 99.6% of all shows
on YouTube never make it
to their 70th episode.
I made up that fact,
Let's put up the made
up fun fact logo there,
and let's go into the show.
You like that, huh, Staphon?
Let's go!
- [Voiceover] Neil asks, "Looking
for a marketing job right
out of college is tough,
especially finding one that's not
sketchy. How do you find a
job that's the right fit?"
- The answer--
Who asked the question, again?
- [India] Neil.
- Neil, it sounds like, by
the way you're asking the
question, I'm glad we're
getting to attack this,
that you're looking at what is deemed as
"Internet Marketing", right?
When you say that all marketing
jobs are scummy out of school,
I think what you're falling
into, is kind of those
e-book, kind of landing page,
the bad version of all these
great growth hackers out there,
the bad version of that, right?
Lowest common denominator,
playing arbitrage, internet
marketing, buy my e-book
in the back room, and the discs, MLM.
It sounds like you're going down a funnel,
and what you deem as marketing
is scummy, and I understand
a lot of that gets into dark
marketing but 98% of the
marketing jobs in the world are
like working at VaynerMedia,
this is marketing. So
first of all, I recommend
recalibrating how you're
positioning marketing,
and make sure that you're not
going down the rabbit hole
of "Internet Marketing", and
I keep quoting it like this--
First, I love air quotes and
we all know that but second,
there is that term for just
copywriting, make landing pages
of red and yellow, and buy
this, and whether you're selling
supplements, or an e-book, or information,
play that game out, that's
not the world of marketing
that I believe in or think about.
So I would tell you that there
are eight billion agencies
marketing, digital,
social agencies out there,
and I would immediately
go get an internship,
if you can't get a job, and
prove that you've got the chops.
It's unbelievable how high of
a percentage of the interns
that we get here at VaynerMedia
we offer a job to. One, we're growing fast,
so that makes sense, but they've
come in and they've hustled
and so the lack of
internship, out of college,
if the market is bad, blows me away.
It seems like the market
is getting better,
jobs are being created more at this scale,
than say, 24-36 months ago.
But the famous DRock story,
or any other story like,
the ability for you to go
and work for somebody pro
bono to get a résumé--
Look, to me, if you're
struggling to get a job for
two, three, four, five
months out of school,
why in the world you wouldn't
take a half of your day,
each day, to then work
somewhere for free, or intern,
whatever it is, to a) pick
up skills, b) network,
c) learn your craft in
action and watch it,
d) create the leverage and
almost guilt your employer
into hiring you, or making
them tell somebody else
to hire you. You know,
better than sitting around
and moping about why it's not working out.
Unless you're out there,
literally, in job interviews
or sending résumés, you've
got 18 hours in a day
to execute this. To me, you
could be doing that from
seven p.m. to two in the morning, and then
from nine to seven, you could go do it.
Go work at a pro bono place, or a museum,
put your skills into action
if you're a marketer.
- [Voiceover] Dana asks,
"How would you advise
a young woman to brand herself on YouTube
if she's worried about privacy
and security for her family?"
- Dana, that's a tough
question for me to answer
because I'm acutely aware that
a lot of practices that I do,
I would struggle to
execute if I was a woman,
and definitely, the thing
that I spend a lot of time
on this lately, serendipitously,
I've been in a couple
of meetings with a couple
of friends, that are
what I would call, very attractive
girls, and that becomes--
Call it whatever you want to call it,
that becomes a whole nother variable.
And so women have it different.
I'm thrilled for people to leave comments,
and I know they will, and say, "No..."
Yes. Women have it different,
African Americans have it
different, Latinos have it
different, context out there
is different. White males
have certain advantages.
And putting yourself out
there, as a woman, leads to
dudes being dudes, what I
mean, dudes are jerk offs,
and they're scum buckets,
and it's just how we roll.
Don't be mad at us, we
were given chemicals
that made us want to be
hunters and we just don't know
how to handle that 94% of the
time, I'm in the six percent.
What I would say is, carefully.
I'm petrified to give an answer
here because if one deems
into an uncomfortable situation
for you, but I think, look--
I think there's different
levels, I mean, the fact--
Here's a good example, it is
very hard to find pictures
of my kids on the Internet, right?
And your question actually
has your child in the picture.
I'm not calling you out
for that, I'm saying,
clearly you have some comfort level
of putting yourself out there.
This is not an answer for
me, or for anybody else,
this is the answer for yourself.
But what I would tell
you is to be careful,
but to recognize people are good.
The number one underrated brand
in the world is human beings.
The mainstream media
spends all of its time
telling us about the terrible
.01% of us, as humans.
But the truth is, it is
stunning, in the world that we
live in now, where
everybody's putting out their
information, where they
are, how they roll,
who their relatives are,
how empty their home is.
Remember when Foursquare came
out, and everyone was like,
"Oh, everybody's gonna rob you", because--
Let's put up that article,
I'm gonna find it.
Put it up here. This was an
article that was literally
written, google right now like
"burglar Foursquare robbing your house".
Everyone's like, "Oh, you
can't check into places
because people are gonna
know you're not home
and they're gonna rob you."
Ludicrous. You found it already?
- [India] There's something
called please rob me.
- Yeah, please rob me. It
doesn't happen because 99.999%
of us, who are watching this
show, living in this world,
are good people. So, look, I'm
not giving you advice on this
because I care way too much
about the health and wellbeing
of your family, and I
care way less than you do.
So you need to roll your
way. But I will say this,
people are good.
It's stunning how
many more bad things
can happen to you by percentage
than the stalker that's
gonna come to your house and hurt you.
It is far riskier to drive
a car than 99% of the things
people talk about around social media.
That's just my context point
but I will not give you
an answer because when it comes to family,
everybody has to make their own decisions.
- [Voiceover] Jonny asks,
"Any tips on giving
a great right hook?"
- Sweep the leg, Jonny. Sweep the leg.
That's literally how I think about this.
The fact of the matter is,
you've gotta go in for the kill.
Just watch, like, Karate
Kid, where that quote's from,
his teammate's like,
"Sweep the leg, Jonny!"
Like, go in for it. How
do you throw a right hook?
Honesty. You know what a good
Super Bowl commercial is,
in my opinion? "Hey, I'm
Gary Vaynerchuk. I'm the CEO
of Toyota. I want you to buy cars from us.
Let us know how we can make that happen."
That's a good Super Bowl
commercial. Forget the pony,
and the eagle, and the cute
dog, and everything else.
You wanna sell cars. I
think that Americans--
You know what? Let's do
a test case right now.
What's Jab, Jab, Jab, Right
Hook's, Amazon ranking right now?
I'm gonna show you, Jonny,
how to sweep the leg.
What's the Amazon rank right now?
Do you know how to find it? I
know how to find it real fast
since I look at it all the
time. You probably don't, India.
I mean, all the time when I'm selling,
I haven't looked at this in
months and months and months.
2,847. That's the rank. Everybody
who's watching this show,
it would mean the world
to me to be able to land
the right hook I'm throwing right now.
A lot of you have the book already.
So it's hard for me to ask--
How much is it on Amazon right now?
- [India] Right now,
it is 17.43, hardcover.
- 17.43, and Kindle?
- [India] 14.99
- 14.99. I am asking every
single person who's watching
this show right now, to buy
one Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
It would mean a lot to me, I
would prove my point to Jonny,
I would equally benefit
from that because I make
a dollar three, a dollar to
three cents, or three dollars
per book, or whatever it
is. At this point I'm done
promoting Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right Hook but it's the most
tangible thing that we
can all watch together,
I'd like you to buy more, if
you were ever thinking about
buying it for your staff, you
can send one for your Kindle,
anybody who's watching,
and if you've watched more
than 25 shows of The
#AskGaryVee Show, and you don't
own a copy of Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right Hook, you need to.
That is absolutely a must.
That is my right hook.
Honestly, Jonny that is--
And I don't know how you can link up.
Obviously, you can't go to Amazon,
but link it in the comments
and that's a right hook.
You just honestly ask, you
try to create some guilt
around it, like "You've watched 30 shows,
can't you give me 15 bucks?",
you try different angles,
you just go straight
for it, you don't hedge,
you ask for the sale of
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
- [Voiceover] Ghopii asks, "How
do you leverage social media
when you're an up and coming actor?"
- You know, Ghopii, I
think one of the things
that you need to be thinking
about is your target audience.
Yes, put out content, I love
the stuff you're putting out,
I love the picture in a public
store, and I've been seeing
the love from you on Instagram,
so I appreciate it, brother.
I think that one of the things
I would do is map the people
that can get you roles in your country.
You probably know the names
of the casting directors,
or the networks that will book you,
literally down to the
name, like Simon Thompson.
Did I nail it, where he's
from? Admit how good I am.
India, tell me. Let's talk
about this. I'm a busy guy.
- Yes.
- [Gary] I'm a busy guy.
- So busy.
- The fact that you could
bring him up right now
and say that, and then I
can tell you which country--
You're impressed, admit it.
- [India] I'm impressed.
- Sorry, that was just for me.
India is just a pure character
and I always love to show her
like how into it I really
am. That's good stuff, right?
- [India] It's really good stuff.
- Thank you. That's enough
DRock. Now you look weird.
Look, I think there's 50-80
people you know the names of,
in Norway, that book the
televisions shows, or commercials,
or whatever you're trying to nail.
So I would go after them directly.
Meaning, I would try to put
content in front of them
on Facebook, if you can buy ads
around the places they work,
I would literally at reply all 80 of them
if they're on Twitter, let's
call four of them are on there,
so you could say hey--
But don't be stalkerish
like, "Hey, book me."
Look for things they're talking
about and reply to that.
In your situation, in many
situations, in a B2B world,
for a lot of people
that are watching this,
find out who you're looking
for and go directly at them.
By either running ads against
them, like, their description,
where they live, their age
group, you can find them
on Facebook dark posts.
Go look at LinkedIn and
see who you're connected to
with them, and maybe put
out content to that person,
and maybe if you have a buddy
who's connected to the person
that you need to get to--
Alright, India's connected
to DRock, we're tight.
But I'm not tight with DRock
and he's a casting person
on channel two in
Norway, it's okay to say,
"India, I'm gonna put out a
video that's really funny.
If you could retweet it,
that would be awesome because
I know that DRock follows
you, and maybe he'll see it."
That's an indirect, direct
way, tangible, black and white
piece of advice that may
lead to the serendipity.
I can go directly to DRock,
or the other thing is DRock
is on Twitter and he tweets
about the presidential election
in Norway, or the King, you know.
And I jump in and get involved there.
There's a lot of ways
to make yourself aware.
It's all tact. It's like
how are you gonna roll up
on that person if you want
a relationship with them?
Whether you're hitting on a
girl, or hitting on a guy--
By the way, did you guys
see the Julian Edelman
Snapchat/Tinder controversy?
Anyway, that just made me think of it.
I've gotta show you
after we're done taping.
There was a business meeting
I was in the other day,
where I wanted to get to the person.
Like, what's my way in
that's not too forceful?
It's almost this imaginary blend of--
What's the blend between
a jab and a right hook?
A "jabrook". There's
something there, so it's tact.
It's always tact. I would
say it starts with--
You've got 80--
I'm gonna assume there's
35-100 people that you know
you need to get to, get to them.
By the way, before we go away,
I know it's gonna be cool.
Please understand, VaynerNation, in 2015,
he can get to those 35-100
people, you couldn't before.
1989, you call like CBS, "Can I speak"--
No, they like--
"We'll transfer you to an assistant."
You couldn't get to people.
That's what the Internet
and what the maturity of the
Internet, the current state of
the Internet, the word we
use to call the Internet
what it is right now, social media, is.
You can, and I don't mean Linkedin,
I've been, as a lot of you
know, been jamming on Linkedin,
I don't mean hit them up and be like--
I mean social. Like talking
to the president of CBS,
on Twitter, about the Super
Bowl, which leads to awareness.
I mean making a piece of
content that gets shared
by their friends so that the
president sees it, of CBS,
you know, that. You can get
to people now. That's huge.
So many of you have gotten
to me, you couldn't have
gotten to me in 1989, there
would've been a secretary
and Ruth would've been like, "No."
Ruth.
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Ishmael, great question.
Not really, actually.
I think it's a very
below average question.
I wouldn't answer it unless
I thought your talent
was so awesome, I basically
am answering this question
strictly for two reasons.
One, you've been a hardcore
part of my community for
the last nine, 10, 12 months
at least. And two, that was
really rad. I love that video
and I'm hoping people who
are watching this show
might hit you up and have you
do something for 500 bucks for
them, I think we should maybe
even use him for something.
Nonetheless, yeah. I don't know.
Question of the day. What
is your Snapchat username?
Because I want to use the
screen to follow some of you.
Here's mine.
Good?
Before I close with my
"you keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering
them", I just want to say
a couple of things. I am
spending enormous amount of time
on Instagram, Snapchat,
Linkedin, Pinterest, Facebook,
Twitter, my friends, we are
living through, I promise you,
I'm gonna look back at this
clip in 35 years and be like,
we are living through
such an interesting time
of communication and marketing,
one that we've not seen--
I actually think the maturity
of the Internet social graph
right now, the most similar
thing was really kind of like--
This is the most I have felt
disruption and opportunity
since the '06 '07, Facebook
and Twitter growth from
let's say, the
MySpace/Friendster beginning.
Please understand that the
next 24 months of hustle
is probably a little bit more
valuable than normal hustle.
Because the stakes are high,
the opportunities are high,
there's a lot of disruption,
people are just settling into
a Facebook and Twitter world and the world
is moving on them. Take advantage.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
The last episode? I don't care.
I like wearing the same clothes.
Clearly, I like this sweater.
Are you sure it wasn't the other blue one?
- [India] I don't remember.
- I have another blue one
that's super close. Show me?
I'm gonna wear the same sweater all week.
In your face, DRock. What
do you think about that?
There's two that are super close.
What are you talking about? In episode 69
I wore a maroon sweater.
You guys are lost.
Yeah, you guys are a bunch of lost--
Well you said--
I thought you were putting
the blame on India.
(crosstalk)
- Nor should you DRock.